good afternoon
folks welcome to the ahern hotel
we're very honored to have you here
today
as i mentioned last night
my family came to this great state
in the 1800s and landed in northern
nevada
nice little town called fallon
i myself was born
i myself was born
right here in las vegas
and i'm a nevadan through and through
i am also proud to be an american
and believe i believe that it is my
patriotic duty to do
what is right for our country
and what is right is supporting
president donald j trump
the decisions we make and the actions we
take
always with specific goals
my goal was to continue
the great american traditions
of the right to assemble
and to free speech
no different than the thousands
that are allowed to assemble
at gaming tables maskless
pool parties
and protest across the street
now i hope we come to an end
of this activity now that our president
has come and gone
and this is all i have to say today and
i want to thank you for being here today
thank you very much mr ahren what do you
think about the fines imposed by the
city of henderson
on extreme manufacturing no questions
thank you we well
as you know we're in we're in some legal
litigation and we understand that
certain agencies
cities are you know they've got a job to
do
they may be being directed
so we respect everybody's position in
this situation
i would i would really not to take
like to not take a lot of questions
today because
we've got uh
we've got fallout happening
and uh maybe tomorrow
we could uh go a little deeper when we
understand what's going on
what do you think thank you ladies and
[Music]
gentlemen
i think that we will give you an ample
opportunity tomorrow
so i thank you very much for today
will there be another press conference
then tomorrow to address the questions
anytime when that